congratulations on jupiter's lex legacy
by the way your character
chloe um she's a rebellious child
of two superheroes she rejects
everything that they've sworn to protect
so what was that did you connect to
chloe's rebellion and her independence
oh my gosh molly do you are you familiar
with the comics at all like are you into
the superior genre like did you know
about jupiter's legacy i'm just curious
i gotta ask
um not before looking into the show by
no comic followings are so dedicated
they know every little detail so that
had to have been
intense it's the i'm not gonna lie
there's some pressure you know you want
to get up to it i hope we do it justice
but to answer your question
yeah she's definitely like you know
she's the bad girl she's very sassy
she's thought
it's funny she's so predictable you
never know what she's gonna say
she will like you know you cross her
molly you will
you know you'll know it and how she
feels she's very raw very unfiltered as
far as her
i love you i mean that's fun to play
myself i mean i don't know if i really
had a rebellious stage
we all have those moments especially
going through puberty
oh yeah when everything is the teenage
angst
it's much but like it's crazy because
she
you know there's she's got a lot of
frustration and stuff
you know bottling up but it's funny
because on the surface it does come
across as angst and whatnot but i really
think it goes deeper than that
she's got a lot of unfortunate she's a
lot of pain
she's kind of alienated herself from her
family she's in that modeling influencer
realm if hollywood and she's kind of
like seeking her parents
acceptance indirectly without even
realizing it through
that very medium even though she hates
it molly she's not like about that life
she hates like the posing and she hates
the um
the element of like uh you know
perfection and being
you know putting up that front because
she feels like that's what her parents
are doing
so she's not you know actively fighting
in the union she's not using her power
she doesn't wear
a super suit or anything but for chloe
in particular
yeah i mean there was a lot to research
online from the books and everything i
tore into that once i found out i had
gotten the part i was like oh shoot
don't blow up time to do the research
and what other ways
do the samson's you know connect to big
families hectic you know they love you
but it's it's a lot of layers you know
you i'm quite impressed you know your
stuff about this story and like the
themes
you know it's it is very much like
family dysfunction which i think
you know myself i come from a very um
chaotic french and greek family so it's
laughing by your greek heritage
and it's like yeah and we've got you
know we have some you know we throw
french in the mix and egyptian
it's very like we got a lot there's
people will think it's we're shouting
and fighting with one another but that's
just the volume
that's just dinner that's like a few
days so
you could there's i feel like no matter
what culture you're from or whatever
side of the globe you're on you'll
relate to
the familial discourse you know the ups
and the downs but in this particular
series it gets really gritty and it
really explores the psyche of these
characters and what makes them tick like
there's
all there's a lot packed into this which
is exciting because
it does stay true to the comic book but
it even gives it a fresh twist
and so it's it's it's gonna be cool to
see what the reaction
is we saw on your instagram a little bit
how much you
trained and how physically demanding the
roles seem so can you give us a look
into that
a little bit well it is very it was very
physical
uh we did like about a month or so i
would say of stunt training prior with
an awesome stunt team
i love that because they gave us like an
introduction to different forms of
martial
arts so martial arts
which i love because i've studied
chinese ballet and i like
to to like to get to learn wushu from
our stunt team
this is like their this is their
specialty you know and to learn it from
them and how it's
very connected to the dance and things i
had learned through there it was
mind-blowing i love that aspect
and i myself am a clumsy individual
molly i don't know about you it was fun
to
like learn it's like how do you properly
tumble how to properly like and make it
look good even though we have our
amazing stunt doubles who
really do the job and mine aleche was
her name she was italian and she was so
she's beautiful studying and like
she taught me she's eating bojitsu and
all these cool things i
can't help myself but when i was you
know thinking of her
meditating on her character i was like
as a greek you can't help it but i
always i love mythology so i was
thinking about
if you were to think about it in the
greek gods of goddesses i would see her
as like the artemis of the group she's
the artemis
i love that she's a fighter she's how
would you characterize her like if you
could think of some adjectives for chloe
and artemis i
i adore that so that's super cool very
she's she's very strong-willed she's
feisty she
like she makes her own rules she follows
her own path
she will tell you how it is like she
doesn't have again doesn't have a filter
she um but she's also deeply feeling
insensitive
and she's so i would say she's
self-destructively and devastatingly
loyal
i first of all i hope you enjoy watching
and i hope that you know girls will feel
empowered
seeing her and her path because she is
again she is such a
strength of spirit which i love whenever
i read scripts and roles i'm like we
always hope that those kind come along
um there are multi-dimensional two not
one note and she's definitely an enigma
an enigmatic character and she's got a
really strong arc too so she starts out
in a really messy place but hey we've
all been there
uh so that's very you know accessible
and relatable we can
you know feel that but she she some of
her questions like
the decisions she make are questionable
at times which again
been there so but she does just make she
makes discovery she learns
about herself she learns about her you
know her family and the love she has
with like i
i really do i hope it does have an
impact um she was inspired by
eddie sedgwick who is such a just a cool
person in general how did that
how did you know that we we got some
notes
um to look into so i'm you know
it's so funny you say that because
people usually say oh it's described by
carrie fisher which she
is and that's a huge that is mark talks
about that all the time and i love that
aspect but the edie cedric one is like
no but
i've never heard anyone catch that so
i'm impressed by you and your
reconnaissance
and i have to tell you i have like we
had pictures like i always make like you
know i have a combination of like
pictures like i would marinate on like
to
think of the character in her vibe and
literally i have so many
uh e cedric pictures on my phone of her
i
the hair alone and everything it's so
they took it away where it's inspiration
but not a
cosplay you know what i'm saying like
the inspiration alone
for the costume design specifically it's
so intricate each character
i was looking to the the press things
for it
how did that feel to see the behind the
scenes aspects of the costume design
what was it like
what were your reactions well i love a
mood board you always love seeing a mood
board when you go into
your costume fittings and you see what
they're planning like oh okay i see it
and like when you go into the fittings
too there's like just tons of clothes
and stuff to play with now particularly
like i had
come off of playing um a girl
comes from the woods from a cult into
juvie so the fashion was fun
in the woods was quite whimsical but in
juvie it was like it was actually the
most comfort i've ever been because it
was just sweat
it's just the jumps flats like then i i
was like
i should have started something joint
well at last because you never know what
is coming next and sure enough chloe
comes along and that was all like
high heels wacky cool outfits because
she's a fashion model you know
and the clothes was so fun molly if you
were
like you you probably would it's so it
was just you wanted to try everything on
they were the most fun outer
like galactic pieces um i've ever seen
you know i've got my stack of jupiter
comics here and chloe you know she's
very much of the pink aesthetic like
like that palette and there's so many
nods throughout again to
her outfit because she only she only
wears that out
one though she was some others but
there's the nods to the iconic looks of
the characters and for everybody like
hutch too he's got some oh my gosh even
like some of these pants he's got these
amazing pants that have like
i don't even know how to describe them
like cherubs and it's like a cool
painting
oh like the fashion is a whole other
thing that's a whole other show on its
own yeah
you know flying that was the first two
getting to experience that and conquer
my fear of heights because i
i still kind of haven't but um uh it
doesn't i don't know is that terrible
a fear of heights and you have to get in
a harness i had to have been
i was trying to think about it and then
the day came where it's like okay
giddy up get in there and put on the
thing but but
the main aspect is like again we have a
group of professionals
uh lifting us up the stunt team like
literally spotting you
they walk you they again baby step you
into the process so and you're watching
all the other act everybody's trying out
like
at first you know like the um inflatable
dude the things outside the dealership
yeah i would say the cardinals yeah yeah
the gumby looking things
yeah this harness because like i was
flailing it's like you can't control it
like it's
you i felt so oh like how am i gonna
make this
work but then you practice you practice
they give you tips and then you
you kind of master it not to the point
obviously of the
stunties but um once you do it it feels
awesome
and i was like okay i'm not scared
because it's more of a mental thing you
know i i knew i was safe i knew they
were below me and then i was like let's
do this thing
i'm trying to understand because it's
probably so it's so much more intricate
than we could even imagine without
seeing it first no
i i kind of realized like the
imagination part really came into play
actually doing children of the corn the
one in australia
stephen king film because there's like
this like when you're
up if there's if there's a monster by
any chance or if there's a creature that
is otherworldly i'm not going to say
there is uh there's literally a
humongous pole with a
tennis ball on it and that is what
you're actually doing you're terrified
you're like what our crew actually put
like a funny face on it
to try and make it but i was like oh it
only made it kind of funnier
so it kind of just floats through the
frame and you're just acting up to maybe
you're horrified maybe you're like oh
maybe you're happy to see it but it's
just like
it's it's like wow this is not what you
think it's gonna be